Let us now look at an example.
Consider a piecewise constant
PDF of the form
shown in this diagram.
Suppose that we condition on the
event that x lies between
a plus b over 2, which
is here, and b.
So we're conditioning
on x lying in this
particular red interval.
What is the conditional PDF?
The conditional PDF is going
to be 0 outside of the
interval on which we
are conditioning.
So the conditional PDF is 0 in
this range, and also, it is 0
in this range.
Within the range of values of
x that are allowed given the
conditioning information, the
conditional PDF must retain
the same shape as the
unconditional one.
And the unconditional one is
constant in that range.
So the conditional PDF will
also be a constant.
Because in this case the length
of this interval is
half of the distance
between b minus a--
so the length of this interval
is b minus a over 2--
in order for the area under this
curve to be equal to 1,
it means that the height of this
curve has to be equal to
2 over b minus a.
The conditional expectation in
this example is just the
ordinary expectation
but applied to
the conditional model.
Since the conditional PDF is
uniform, the conditional
expectation will be the midpoint
of the range of this
conditional PDF.
And in this case, the midpoint
is 1/2 the left end of the
interval, which is a plus b over
2 plus 1/2 the right end
point of the interval,
which is b.
And so this evaluates to 1/4
times a plus 3/4 times b.
We can also calculate the
expected value of X squared in
the conditional model using
the expected value rule.
According to the expected value
rule, it's going to be
an integral of the conditional
PDF, which is 2 over b minus a
multiplied by x squared.
And this integral runs over
the range where the
conditional PDF is actually
non-zero.
So it's an integral that
ranges from a plus b
over 2 up to b.
And this an integral which is
not too hard to evaluate, and
there's no point in carrying out
the evaluation to the end.